you know
stay with me on this this might be a
leap but it's my leap so i'm totally
gonna take it
this movie
is the best resident evil movie we've
ever gotten
kind of in a way
but a way that's worth it
so barbarians written and directed by
zach craiger who's i don't think i've
seen any of his movies at all i think
back when i worked at the movie theater
i might have seen miss march but that's
it but judging by barbarian dude might
just have a bright future ahead of him
so the premise of barbarian i'm gonna
keep it vague because the trailer was
vague
thank you trailer thank you trailer to a
mysterious horror movie for remaining
mysteriously vague it is appreciated
among we the audience but the premise is
essentially there's a character played
by georgina campbell she goes to this
house as an airbnb and there's someone
there played by alexander skarsgard and
from there place might be a house of
horrors i'm sorry i need to keep it
vague because that was the fun of this
movie for me this is the first movie in
a very long time i knew
nothing about i didn't know what the
trailer looked like i didn't know what
the movie was about i heard nothing
about the movie i heard no buzz i didn't
know what the critic reception was i
have heard no drama surrounding the
movie all of it was very refreshing and
led to me having a very
mysteriously fulfilling horror movie
experience in the theater because the
first act of this movie
is absolutely some of the best
horror slash thriller movie tension i
have seen in probably years you don't
know who to trust you don't know what's
going on everything looks fine but it's
you know
it's a movie with that poster so
obviously everything's not gonna be fine
and it's that uncertainty mixed with the
endless possibilities and path of horror
movie unknowns that this movie could
take damn it that was the fun of it
georgina campbell was great in this
movie and although this movie does
bounce to other characters she stands
out and the back and forth in chemistry
she has with alexander skarsgard that
brought me into it justin long plays a
[ __ ] bag and he plays him so well zero
regard for people around him like
there's one scene where he opens up her
laptop types in it for a second and
shuts it and throws it the way he lobs
it you're like no one does that [ __ ]
human beings do it's also darkly funny
and it usually has to do
with again justin long like when he's
measuring this room for the square
footage and you're like you
you're not looking at the room i don't
know why that cracks me up this movie
does have that horror meet social
commentary angle usually revolving
around justin long's character but also
a conversation with two other characters
all in all it did weave it into this
movie very well this movie has some
disturbing imagery in it too and i want
to clarify i'm not necessarily talking
about violence though this movie does
have sparing use of violence but when
the violence happens like oh that's
undeniably bloody let's know what i'm
talking about what i'm talking about is
disturbing imagery which isn't
necessarily the same as violence i
always appreciate it when a filmmaker
knows that those two are not the same
that they are separate i will say though
like i said the first act
chef's kiss in terms of tension the
second and third acts are never as
strong as that first act in fact in the
third act there are some things that go
down you're like was that cheesy
it was a bit cheesy
still really enjoying the movie as a
hold up that's when you know you found
something special is when it can throw
things that kind of come across as
cheesy but you're like but it didn't
compromise it
i respect that guys in the end barbarian
was a surprisingly enjoyable horror
movie experience once in a while you see
a movie come along and you think about
the premise and the execution you're
like that would have been right at home
in 70s 80s error horror but it's
undeniably a modern take of that so it's
this really fun merging of the decades
of horror it wasn't overinflated it was
a nice run time of about an hour and 40
minutes and in the end i walked out
having myself a great time no alcohol
required i know there's a new pinocchio
live action movie out there on disney
plus but
i like me a good enjoyable horror movie
i feel like you might too i feel like
this was worth getting out there first
alright so barbarian have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you